[Applaudissements]
les cherry on est dans l'ascenseur
regardez je suis avec le patron je suis
avec toutes les voix je suis trop
regarder la thierry moreau chéri on va
l'en plateau les amours dans un instant
ça y est on est prêts on est partis
regarder ya estelle denis est celle de
nicky sorte de touche pas à mon sport
voilà la syrie cbg skate tout va bien
cette chemise c'est vrai elle va vous
coller à moi qu'à valérie benaïm viande
et verdure des enseignants des l'imprévu
si on regarde ça et je fais mes joueurs
qu'on arrive en bas de chez toi et je te
dis au revoir et l'apc de mon passé je
te mets à l'évasion
je fais la scène ouais alors bhaskar
débat alors on arrive on assume en asie
lorsque les gens vont pas sa vie salut
les sixties ce que tu fais ce qui nous
arrive à temps je te fais mon travail
ouais enfin non ça n'inquiète l'homme
est en toi tu mesures tu me suis battu
c'est un pari
[Applaudissements]
je suis super content de passer la
soirée pour m6 était fonctionnel
[Applaudissements]
du mois mais je tape l'a21
[Rires]